Xiaomi vient de lancer des lunettes à
réalité augmentée pour venir réinventer
l'interface homme machine c'est vraiment
génial en fait l'idée c'est regarder
dans le futur et de venir se passer de
son smartphone et devenir faire tout ce
qu'on fait avec son smartphone mais
grâce à des lunettes connectées des
grâces à des lunettes à réalité
augmentée alors là il nous les présente
sur un salon on peut pas les essayer on
peut pas les montrer à tout le monde
finalement c'est extrêmement chaude et
j'ai vraiment eu la chance de pouvoir
les voir en avant première donc ça c'est
génial donc on peut venir faire quoi
bien du gaming on peut venir imaginer et
bien de la modélisation aux trois
dimensions pour un archi j'en sais
fiston moyen bref il y a plein d'usages
qui peuvent venir faire c'est
extrêmement intéressant pour l'instant
c'est que le début il y a plein de
constructeurs qui commencent à se
positionner sur des lunettes à réalité
augmentée une fois de plus pour dire
réinventer l'interface homme machine et
en plus de ça ce qui est très cool avec
ses lunettes c'est qui nous les montre
avec des vers transparents également
avec des verres un peu plus fumés alors
ça pourrait venir se moduler directement
sur la même paire de lunettes et puis ça
pourrait s'adapter également au myope
bref c'est malin c'est intelligent c'est
une innovation qui est signée Xiaomi ça
arrivera potentiellement à l'avenir
dites-moi ce que vous en pensez dans les
commentaires est-ce que ça pourrait vous
intéresser oui non quoi comment vous
marquez ça et puis on en parle très
bientôt voilà on y va
[Musique]